it's time to reform the filibuster that
was a very tired
president joe biden talking about his
plan to reduce the rise in homicides and
shootings across the country
basic component of the plan more money
for quote-unquote programs that work and
a laser focus on cracking down on
illegal
gun trafficking i don't personally
believe
that that kind of crackdown is gonna do
a den in any of the
violence that we're seeing here in this
country but i noticed a few things degen
that he did not mention
he did not mention gangs he did not
mention the drug trade
the importance of fatherhood longer
sentences to keep these people off the
street and
proactive policing which actually would
reduce
these shootings he didn't talk about the
root causes of the spike in crime
he said it's not a red or a blue issue
yes it is
it's a blue issue because the death and
destruction that we're witnessing
in major cities across the country is
designed
by democrats joe biden needs to stand up
there rather than
talking about the gun lobby and going
after federal
firearms licensed dealers he needs to
say
i stand up for the police i stand up for
the victims
i stand up for the terrorized citizens
and residents
of all of these cities and we will go
after
the criminals let me quote joe biden
from 1994
lock the sobs up but instead
he and kamala harris are just trying to
paper over the carnage
this was the equivalent of some old
coupe coming into the office
and walking around with a clipboard
trying to act like he's doing something
and he's not getting anything done one
final thought
in addition to the defund demoralize and
defang the police movement
by all of the liberals joe biden and
kamala harris stand up
for bail reform it is part of their
policies
so no bail
get out of jail if you're arrested let
me go back
and look at in the original bail reform
bill here in new york city which is one
of the reasons that crime has spiked
these are some of the people that
democrats think should go back out on
the street
someone promoting or possessing a sexual
performance by a child
reckless assault of a child no jail
manslaughter hate crimes and arson
that's
who the democrats are and we saw none
of the ability of joe biden to talk down
what's happening in this country geraldo
your reaction to this
address as we saw and have been
reporting murders up
800 percent in the city of portland 50
people
shot over the weekend in chicago
shootings up 75
in new york city the president did not
seem fully engaged and
as compassionate as you would expect
someone
to be in that position well i compassion
aside where was the passion
i mean that that speech was as laid back
as the program that he proposes yeah
what is he proposing summer programs for
uh endangered youth
and uh stopping the illegal sale of
firearms
what about the fact that you mentioned
chicago eight people killed
54 shot last weekend that's an emergency
that's something that needs action right
now take that 600 or
rather 360 billion dollars that he
proposes spending on these programs
use that to have stop and frisk in
chicago let's have stop and frisk with
federal assistance
in chicago it's constitutional let's
have roadblocks let's go after the
these uh these gangs as organized
criminal enterprises
under rico statutes you've got to make
this the emergency that it is
that was very very sleepy and you know i
like the guy but that was pathetic
and i and was not in any way it seemed
to me totally reactive to the bad press
they scramble to get something uh you
know something done
they could be much more emergent it's
much more
uh you know serious than it was
portrayed by the president of the united
states just there
and dana very focused on guns but not
the people that are
shooting the guns do you think that
going after illegal gun traffickers
here and there is going to do anything
to stop the bloody summer that everybody
expects
i i think it could help a little bit but
to heraldo's point
what president biden just did did not
meet the moment right and i one of the
things i thought of was this um
community leaders in chicago that are
trying so hard
imagine that you're them and you're
watching that thinking well that's
not gonna do a darn thing to help us and
let's remember why is president biden
doing this speech today anyway
because like on the border with kamala
harris now going on friday they
that's where they are the most weak when
it comes to their politics
so they know they're taking on water on
that issue so they said we better slap
something together real quick get the
attorney general over here
write a two-long speech for the
president and have him read it as if he
was
reading back somebody's fast food order
yeah in a drive-through
and that's why i say it just doesn't
meet the moment they the democrats
should consider
fox their early warning system for
problems yeah this is not something
like we're like uh guys anybody over
here so want to
take a look at this crime last point is
it's interesting that he would say that
the american rescue plan
had money in there and and was aimed at
reducing crime
well that bill has been out there for
three months all we've seen
is crime increase and i know it takes a
while to get money out there but money
is not necessarily going to solve this
problem
the last thing i would say is that he
says that you
the cities states you are welcome
to use extra coveted relief money to pay
for police
so now are they for funding the police
but with money that was supposed to go
for covid
and if we have that much money sloshing
around out there perhaps we didn't need
that much stimulus in the first place
greg last word from you yeah the uh two
points you made so they're proposing
more police
meaning we are back exactly where we
were before
the media and the democrats had hijacked
the george floyd
uh uh tragedy to reduce the police right
so i think now we're all supposed to
pretend that this like
year-long delusion that they all shared
suddenly just
no longer exists and we can now return
back to the good old days
when we trusted our police and we needed
our police um
now they're getting around to this and
they're getting around to this because
they think that they can put it on guns
rather than on themselves right so we
were the
we were the canaries in the crime mine
we were pleading for help through this
whole thing
and while we were pleading for it the
folks over at cnn were laughing at us
right
they were and they were purposely
turning their cameras away from the
crime
and you could not expose what was going
on because if you exposed that you could
show
how the media was culpable in all of
this um
all of the people like the best spokes
the best spokesman
for the nra is that guy joe biden
the democratic party the media there
were five million new legal gun owners
uh last year and it wasn't because of
wayne lapierre
right have you seen him no eight million
yeah is eight million now no it was jeff
zucker
it was kamala harris it was beto
o'rourke and everyone else who
simultaneously excused the mob violence
while denigrating the fears of a
population i have said this before i am
now more pro-gun
than i ever have been in my life and i
will continue to be
i i want everybody to own a gun every
law abiding person should have a gun
because in this crime spike the guns
were there before
and the guns were thereafter so that
variable doesn't play
into the crime wave it's not about gun
violence at all it's about violence
and how we live in a culture a climate
change
we've had a change in our climate where
we now
regard law and order as the bad guy and
the bad
guy as the victim that's where we are
and if we don't change that thinking
we're screwed and i almost used a
different word
go ahead i just want to add one thing i
know i already ran my mouth way too much
but the why now is eric adams
former police officer a man who promised
to carry a gun
if he's the mayor of new york city is
very close to winning the democratic
nomination
you know who voted for him black and
latino voters
in the outer boroughs not the elites not
the snots
in manhattan this party is turning
against them
and they know it this is the civil
rights issue of our time
murder has become the leading cause of
death among black men up to the age of
44.
it's if this is not an emergency what
the hell is yeah but also you have to
remember
the burned destructive buildings in
kenosha in minneapolis
that wasn't caused by guns by bad
people right as i would quote tyrus it's
not it's we don't need gun control
we need bad people control and the white
house seems totally out of touch with
what's going on in the streets
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else